If we was the problem then we are the solution to a lot of the violence that’s going on in the streets in L.A.
We ought to be able to create safer
neighborhoods, safer parks.
Parks that shouldn’t be known for a shoot-up gallery.
So, Reynaldo got this idea some time ago that one way to bring peace to the neighborhoods…
there’s always fighting…the gangs are
always fighting with each other…
he said, ‘let’s play some baseball.’
And I thought, hmmm, here’s an opportunity.
Our students got experience
they would get in no other way.
OK, home team, take the field.
These brothers here, in these neighborhoods,
are coming together for the softball
It ain’t about just softball.  It’s about making a difference.
Our lives, our children’s lives, our community as a whole.